claudia is with us in las vegas hi
claudia how are you
i'm well how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up in your world
hi so i just found you about a few
months ago
and um i don't know where to start with
this conversation because
um we were a family we're a family of
five
um we were an income of thirty thousand
dollars my husband was the sole provider
i was a stay-at-home mom
living in orange county california with
our parents
[Music]
and we had to get out of there we were
on welfare we were struggling
it was just bad so we moved to nevada
for a fresh start
my husband got transferred out here for
work so um
once my kids started school i started
working so i've been working now full
time
for a year and a half so together we are
now
bringing a hundred thousand um take home
page
wow look at you yeah so
um it's just been very stressful though
like when i found you
i felt i felt like i finally found
someone who i can listen to
and look up to and follow your baby
steps um
we finally got out of baby step zero
but we can't figure out how to move
forward
we only have twenty dollars in our bank
account
um and i don't know what to do
okay where's all you're making a hundred
thousand where'd it all go
um just getting current with bills
um and just trying to keep our
household running without government
assistance
um with a hundred thousand dollars you
can do that
yeah but we haven't finished um this is
going to be the first time we hit the
thousand dollars
this year so that you hit a hundred
thousand
so when so you're making eight thousand
dollars a month
how many months ago did that start
um that started in june okay where has
that gone
where'd it go just
seeing bills getting current on our four
walls
okay fifty thousand dollars worth
yeah i don't know i don't know
i started learning how to budget and
since june i've been i know i've been
trying to budget i've been listening to
rachel cruz
on her youtube i'm trying to figure out
how to
you know get this budgeting thing so
let's just let's just stop a second
let's look at some basic stuff
okay you got 8 000
at the beginning of the month yes now
let's just pretend this month is
december
and we're going to figure out where that
money's going how much is your rent
1200 12.68 okay that leaves us 6 800
okay and um how much is your lights and
water
um we're on a payment plan so we're
doing
um like 300 for likes and water
okay that leaves us 6 500
how much are your car payments um
910 dollars okay that leaves us 5 500
okay and what other big bills have you
got
we have um internet because we're
working from home and kids are home from
school
that's not a big bill i said big bills
yep what have you got that's over
three hundred dollars a month
oh nothing okay where did five thousand
five hundred dollars go then
um i guess food food five thousand
dollars on food
no 400 on food okay
okay but you see what i just did i took
eight thousand dollars and i put it at
the top of the page
and i took care of food shelter clothing
transportation and
utilities and we're still at five
thousand dollars left over give or take
after your four walls are current yeah
i'm just
not budgeting correctly budgeting is
giving every dollar
a name that's what rachel told you right
you're also doing this by yourself your
husband's not helping you
he says he's on board no he's not
helping you do the budget
he's not no the two of you need to sit
down together
and give every one of your dollars a
name for
december before december begins and
since it just began you go do it right
now
yes look at what you've got coming in
and
give it a name every one of those
dollars that's a zero-based budget
and jump on every dollar and start using
the app to do that
it's free you can do that or start you a
free trial on ramsey plus
one of the two but um there's something
happening in your emotions
where you feel like this stuff is
controlling you and some reason you
can't go control it and all i'm telling
you is you got to get up on top of it
and put your foot on its neck and don't
let this money leave without having a
game plan
claudia i want you to answer that i
think you're about ready to blurt it out
i want you to be really really gut level
honest
why are you not doing this what's
keeping you from
sitting down with your husband and doing
this
um honestly just
i think i'm right at this point i'm just
it's so intense
my husband's just more like you know
i'll let you deal with it
here's my check and figure it out okay
so let's stay there we're not on the
same page
yeah that's absolutely clear but hold on
a second if he's saying that and i'm
and i don't like that but this is all
new let's give him a little bit of grace
here what's keeping you from sitting
down
since he's supposedly giving you the
green light to do it and he's
essentially
transferring his responsibilities to you
what's keeping you from sitting down and
doing this
i do um you should see my desk i have i
have but
i have planners i have calendars i
pronoun i budget
okay so hold on okay all right so what's
happening is is that you
you're either showing that to him or not
showing that to him if you are showing
that to him he's not
living up to it and he's just spending
and you're spending is that right
that's correct so a budget that you
don't live by is useless
yeah yeah the two of you need to agree
on where these dollars are going to go
in advance and then stick to
your agreement yeah you're doing
theoretical budgets in the clouds that
you've never actually applied to your
life there's no behavior change see the
budget is to guide your behavior it
literally says
you can't spend more than x amount of
dollars let's just look at your budget
you said 400
on groceries that's not enough that's
not enough but let's say that it's six
seven hundred dollars
that's your guideline so then you write
down 400 on a piece of paper and then go
spend 900
at the grocery store because you just
ignored the budget because the budget
was a theory
or he is too and so this is your boss
it's like when you were a little kid and
you said you're not the boss of me
well you're the budget's not the boss of
you until you get it done
and then once you get it done it's the
boss of you
it's telling both you and your husband
every
dollar where it's going and you're both
going to stinky pinky square and spit
shake and stick to that
and that's where this overwhelming thing
comes from and it's like you're
spiraling out there
and somehow this stuff is whipping your
butt you need to get up on it and punch
it in the nose and he
listen you need to sit down with him
tonight turn off television put the kids
to bed take his hands in your hands and
say i need you to be my man
i need you to man up bubba by the way
claudia
this is also live on youtube you need to
take him to today's show right here
in this moment about the 40th minute or
so the first hour and you need to make
him watch this because dave and i just
told him hey dude
you need to step up and help your wife
she's hurting you need to man up
well the two of you working together i
mean this thing i'm going to make the
money and you take care of it
she's not your mother that's right you
need to work together
on this stuff there's all the data tells
us everything for 30 years of doing this
tells us you can't get on top of it when
you're not working together
it's not a matter of gazelle intensity
it's a matter coming into agreement on a
budget
and then freaking sticking to it